my head literally exploded from the
cuteness that's just from the little
short film at the beginning of the Pixar
movie - how every Pixar movie has a
little short film at the beginning yet
that one I was unprepared adorable all
right I'm at the movie review
finding dory so finding Dory is a sequel
to Finding Nemo in this movie dory
starts getting fragments of memories
about her parents and she's like whoa I
have parents I have a family I need to
go find him so with the help of Nemo and
Nemo's pops Dory sets out to find her
parents which is funny it's called
finding Dory because Dory is the one
looking for her parents should be called
Dory finding grammaton how and when I
heard this movie was coming out it was a
mix of excitement and concern because
there's a part of me it's like awesome
that they're going at that again because
Finding Nemo is awesome and there's that
party you're like are you trying to melt
this or do you really feel like there's
a story to be told honestly there's a
story to be told and it's quite a good
one first of all Ellen DeGeneres is
great as dory it's always a risk taking
a support character from one movie and
giving that character the lead in their
own movie but it totally works here
which also makes room for new flavorful
supporting characters in this movie and
they have on the supporting characters
here are great
one in particular Hank the octopus I
love that dude can next one be finding
Hank where Hank is actually set out to
find his own maybe he's looking for his
arm I don't know I'm just saying Hank
was great and Hank and Dory together
they're the ones their friendship
actually carries this movie just kind of
weird you would think it's like her and
Nemo Orson but it's not it's Hank and
just a general heart its Pixar for god
sakes I have this down to a science
adventure excitement
laughs Hart the fails and what I love is
the satirical view you know it's like to
us human beings we interact with animals
and see marine life like it's just no
big deals like oh yeah we're just doing
our thing nothing scary about that but
to them it could be like a horror movie
one segment in this movie man it just
illustrates that perfectly it's one of
my favorite scenes I can say this though
at a point near the beginning of this
movie I was like if I knew Dory
personally and I had to interact with
Dory
I wouldn't have the patience for it man
I would beat my head against the wall
it's frustrating so you get that is
frustrating for those around her to
interact with her doesn't change the
fact that when they get frustrated with
Dory you feel bad for Dory because
you're like she can't help it she just
can't remember things and that also
makes following these breadcrumbs that
she has in her head really her
subconscious interesting most of the
time it's like follow the clues and it
leads you to step two step three step
four Step five with her it's a little
different because
just these unreliable memories in the
bag in the recesses of her mind that
kind of vaguely point to a clue and even
then she's probably gonna take a wrong
turn after that in a wrong turn after
that because she's going to interpret it
wrong it's a cool take on the follow the
breadcrumbs thing I can say that this
movie feels like it gears down near the
end or at least one of the endings
because I feel like this movie was
aiming to end about three times like
it's ended note nope it's not ending
alright that are okay now it's good a
note we're still doing stuff and what
they're doing is interesting enough just
made for kind of an unstable
rollercoaster that I'm on now and then
when the movie ends is just kind of like
oh two ends you're like oh abrupt end
credits alright I guess now we're done
but in the end guys finding dory is
great you have the laughs you have the
tears you have the feels the beginning
of this movie the feels are real there
is a scene in this movie dory b/w she's
at her lowest low and you really feel
despair I feel like this movie has the
unfortunate task of battling the
nostalgia that everyone has and holds
near and dear to their hearts of finding
Nemo don't look at it as a battle just
look at it as a companion piece I will
certainly say finding Dory is definitely
worth watching and definitely worth
buying on blu-ray I really feel like
statistically everybody I say
statistically everybody because that
still leaves that variance of people who
won't go I'm talking 99.9% of people who
watch this movie will like this movie it
all depends on how much they like it
between like and love alright guys so
finding dory have you seen it what did
you think about it how does it compare
to Finding Nemo for you whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to say more
you